pour l'avion de sang il ya 44 ans la loi
veil encadrant la dépénalisation de
l'avortement en france était adoptée à
l'assemblée nationale une scène rejouer
ces 3 juillet 2019 par 40 étudiantes et
étudiants de l'ue vs qu en revivant ses
segments importants pensent les
appropriant yayi ils ont une meilleure
appréhension des problèmes soulevés
meilleure compréhension des problèmes
soulevés et sûrement une mémoire plus
longue
tout un symbole pour lui vécu qui
donnait en 2012 le nom de simone veil à
son nouvelle ufr santé cette
reconstitution a permis aux étudiants de
revivre les débats houleux de cette loi
emblématique
[Musique]
parce qu'on a réussi à reconstituer
l'ambiance électrique de l'assemblée
nationale quelque chose que ce n'était
pas évident sous ces petites phrases ces
réactions ces insultes on a été assez en
adéquation avec le contexte actuel avec
l'alabama où finalement libéré n'est
plus autorisée et oui une prise de
conscience de se dire que on a une
chance incroyable qui finalement un jour
que je ne plus être autorisés étaient
présents dans l'assemblée le secrétaire
d'état pour la jeunesse gabriel attal ou
encore l'ancien ministre de la santé
marisol touraine
ils ne se sont pas contentés de jouer le
débat ils se le sont appropriés ont fait
en sorte de forte des questions
auxquelles on n'était pas forcément
préparé et attentif il ya eu plusieurs
moments de vrais échanges j'ai trouvé
entre les étudiants eux mêmes et avec
les participants au débat
cette innovation pédagogique sera
reconduite par l'ue vs qu l'année
prochaine avec la reconstitution du
procès des médecins nazis de nuremberg
gh